[Music]
hello everyone
as mentioned in the overview lecture
previously
we are first going to discuss uh the
beam theory as it pertains
only to the lateral loading which
induces
simply and only the bending of beams
okay so the as per our
uh as per our overview again what we are
going to do
is first of all
consider the principle of stationary
potential energy
develop our theory and then go on to the
principle of virtual work
so first of all based on the principle
of stationary potential energy
okay so uh
let me draw the the beam here
please note that uh
i am drawing these kinds of jagged ends
here
uh meaning to do to
to signify that i am right now
not interested in the
specific kinds of boundary conditions
which may be present
at the actual ends of the beams they can
be clamped
they can be simply supported it does not
matter right now
and this this statement that it does not
matter right now
it is directly connected with the
general nature of the theory
which we are trying to derive here
so let me set it out very clearly
uh at the very beginning that our
objective here
when we say that we wish to find out or
which
or we wish to develop the beam theory it
is
our our goal our final goal to develop
an equation for the deflection of the
beam
a governing equation together with the
set of appropriate boundary conditions
for the deflection of the beam because
once we know the deflections
we know the material behavior we know
the geometrical aspects
we can find out the strains we can find
out the stresses
everything okay so since our theory
will be general enough it should be able
to capture
various kinds of boundary conditions so
right now we do not have to specifically
mention
which boundary condition this is about
when we go
now when when you address specific
problems
then then you can you can
you can specialize the general theory to
that particular boundary condition
okay so uh in a similar fashion our
load the lateral load will also be
general enough
so
it need not be uniformly distributed so
that's what i am representing here
some general kind of distribution of the
load
i hope you get the idea all right but
please note that there is no axial
loading here
now because we wish to proceed by the
principle of stationary potential energy
let me write down the expression of the
potential energy at the very outset
so this pi the capital pi
this is equal to the v internal plus v
external
and v internal we have seen earlier in
our previous chapter
while dealing with the caustic linus
theorem of deflection
that this being internal the potential
energy
equivalently the strain energy this can
be written
for the case of beams
in this fashion
now i have suddenly written this
statement okay i have suddenly written
down this formula
but there is a lot of backstory up
behind it
so now i strongly advise you
that uh if you are not too confident
with what just went on here from this
jump
of this potential energy to this strain
energy expression
i strongly advise you to please go back
to the appropriate portion
of the appropriate video from the
previous chapter
and take a look there
there will be a couple of other comments
to make also which i will
uh which i'll make subsequently for the
external
uh potential energy this can be directly
uh connected
to the work done by this
external distribution of forces so
please note that
uh this loading it
it is generally given by this
q which can be a function of x
and uh the work done
over a little elemental length of the
beam
is this cube wdx
and that is integrated over the entire
length of the beam
now this is the work done what we have
to actually write down or what we
actually interested in
is to write down the expression for the
v external or the external potential
energy
so all that you could do is to write
this with a negative sign
okay so uh what do we do with
what we do with this now so we have to
use the principle of stationary
potential energy
so
so all that we need to do is to apply
this thing
which means that we are basically going
to
start our work
from here
the first variation of that entire
expression that we had written earlier
is equal to zero so this basically is
the first
first line of our application of the
principle of stationary potential energy
now let us try to
[Music]
to move our attention back to our
original goal
as i had mentioned uh our original or
our final goal here
is to find a governing equation for the
deflection of the beam this w
note it does indeed represent the
deflection
okay so please note that w here
is the deflection of the beam
the deflection means that how much
uh this beam is going to deflect
from the straight orientation okay so
when it curves down like that
how much is the deflection uh from that
from that horizontal orientation and
that you understand
will be very much a function of x
uh i have made a slight mistake here
this
delta should not come here that will
come later
so this is right now just like this
and this dx is also inside sorry about
that okay
so we write that down better
okay that's better now
now we do have the presence of this
deflection here
so that gives us some hope that we
should be able to obtain some kind of
a of an equation involving the w but
what about this expression
this is expressed in terms of this
young's modulus this i here is the
second moment of area of the moment of
inertia
and m here is the bending moment so
there is no sign of the w
right now so this is the part
where we have to use our knowledge from
the
from our undergraduate studies so what
we are going to use here
is
is this well-known formula which
which especially the people who have had
a wonderful gate preparation should
have the at their fingertips so this m
is the bending moment this e and i are
the same e and i that are present here
this ray r here is the radius of
curvature and we have
actually discussed this uh in connection
with uh solving problems
uh based on the castigliano's theorem on
deflections in the previous chapter
so this
m is basically e i by
r okay now this
r here this radius of curvature
the radius of curvature here uh it can
be written down
in terms of the deflection
like this
so what i have done here is to basically
write down the deflection here
in the radius of curvature here
in terms of the derivatives of the
deflection
and please note that when i do this i am
not appealing to any knowledge
from the from our undergraduate studies
of beings or mechanics of solids i am
not
at all appealing to that kind of thing
rather what i am appealing to here or
what i am using here
is our knowledge from uh from our first
here
engineering mathematics curriculum okay
so when we study the
various kinds of curves uh and
and the representation of the of the
curvature
uh based on the first and second
derivatives
up we do come up with this kind
of formula uh there and it is
that exact formula you can actually
refer back to any of the standard
textbooks of
uh engineering mathematics uh this is uh
it is here at iit kharagpur it was it is
taught in our first year itself
uh and i'm sure in many colleges um
also it is taught in the first year so i
i sincerely request you
to take a look back at that if if you
don't remember this
okay now uh what we are going to do is
we are going to make the approximation
that this
is approximately equal to d
squared w dx squared where we are
basically saying
that the slope dwdx here
is not too large okay so this basically
works
under the assumption that
dwdx this magnitude
is much much less than one all right
so what we can do here
is
this m can be replaced by this e i by r
so that what we have
here is this half e i
uh 1 by r square dx
and in the subsequent step we can
replace
uh this
1 by r by this
d squared w dx square again that's
exactly what we are
going to do okay so let me go to the
next slide
and carry out the steps but before we do
all
any of that uh i want to emphasize on
something extremely extremely important
you please note that when we are
proceeding in this fashion when we have
written down
this expression when we are using these
formulae
we are implicitly basing
our derivation and our theoretical
development
on the euler bernoulli beam hypothesis
on the one hand
as well as on the linear elastic
material behavior on the other hand okay
so
inherent uh in all of these derivations
is the euler bernoulli beam hypothesis
let me write down here
okay so we are very much working
under the assumptions of the euler
bernoulli
beam hypothesis which we all study in
our undergraduate
mechanics of solids
euler bernoulli beam hypothesis as well
as we are using this
linear elastic
material behavior
so when i say euler-bernoulli beam
hypothesis
what i basically mean is uh the kind of
assumptions where we say that when a
beam
is bending uh the plane sections
they remain plain and undeformed
as well as the assumption that the plane
section
remains perpendicular to the
longitudinal axis of the beam
okay so it is those kinds of simplifying
assumptions that all of this theory is
based on
furthermore uh
the these kinds of relations this m r is
equal to e i
it is very much dependent on the use of
the linear elastic material behavior
okay so as you have seen in one of the
problems
of uh where we used a non-linear
material behavior in castigliano's
theorem on deflections
you saw that the connection between this
this or this relation m r equal to e is
no longer valid
we do end up with a with a different
kind of formula
okay so so it is very much linear
elastic material behavior here
so despite this restrictive assumptions
you'll see that
this kind of a theory is very much
applicable to a large number of typical
engineering situations which is why it
is still popular
and not just as a
simple fundamental teaching tool okay so
without any further discussion let me
get into the into the take of things of
this derivations will proceed from this
on this line so let me actually copy
this thing and proceed from there and
copy this part
and then move on
sorry about that my writing app
sometimes just misbehaves
okay
copy this and i'll proceed from here
so first of all uh i have i
i considered
the replacement of this 1 by r by this
d squared w dx square
square of that because this is 1 by r
square
this dx and then
we have this term
all right now we carry out uh
the simplifications uh involving the
first variation
so let me write down the steps
uh i hope you should be able to follow
it i'll do it step by step
so this half e i remains as it is
we carry out the first variation over
this term
uh this is
giving us twice d squared w
dx squared and then
d squared delta w
dx squared so you please note that when
i'm writing this
i'm basically making a one
one jump of a step in going from
delta of d square w dx square to this d
squared delta w d x square so i hope it
won't be any problem
in a similar fashion for this second
term we don't have to worry about the
variability of this q
because that is given to us it is the
first variation of the deflection
which we are interested in all right
so this first term
is like this
from now on uh whatever we do is just
some mathematical tricks
up and the good thing is that we really
wanted to get to the stage
where we could apply some mathematical
tricks without having to worry
uh at every step about uh
about our understanding of mechanics of
soil so we want to proceed in a very
algorithmic
systematic fashion to obtain our uh our
our governing equations and boundary
conditions and this is the part
where this is basically just calculus of
variations
okay so this is the full-fledged
application of what we studied in our
first chapter now there is the there's
the only motivation here
that this term here involves
the second derivative of the first
variation of
the deflection while this is just the
first variation of the deflection
standing alone
now what we would like to have is a
term involving so you see both of these
are integrations from 0 to l0 to l so
what we would like to have
is is a term which
does not involve any such derivatives
rather
a term which only involves this first
variation of delta w
just in the same fashion that we have
the first variation of the delta w here
or the first variation of w
here okay you see there are no
derivatives of this delta w
so we want to transform this term in a
fashion
such that these d square dx square it
disappears
so how can we do that we have a
mathematical machinery for that and that
is
the integration by parts so exactly so
that's exactly what we are going to
do we we carry out uh the integration by
parts once
you obtain a term like this
so these are the boundary terms minus
integration 0 to l and then we have
the ddx of
ei
what we have done here basically is
uh we have considered this e i d square
w d x squared to be
the the the first
uh term in the in the integration by
parts and this is the second term
so in the boundary term it is this thing
which gets integrated
and in the integration term it is this
term this first one which gets
differentiated okay along with the
integration
of this second term also so we have this
so as a result of this integration by
parts once
what we have ended up is one step closer
to what we wanted what we want is
this kind of a term like delta w here
also so we are one step closer so
earlier we had the second derivative
involving the first variation of w
now we have the first variation of the
delta w so if we can do
another integration by parts then we
should be absolutely
be left with a term which does involve
of this delta w without any
without any derivatives so we'll do that
again this boundary term remains as it
is
so we are going to carry out another
integration by parts
where again we are considered we are
going to consider this as our
uh our first term and this is the second
term
so uh this is going to be uh
so i i'll also carry out another
simplification here
uh by considering that this e i here is
a constant
so that i can take that out of the
integration
out of this differentiation so this is
e i d cube w
d x cube
then i have this delta w because i'm
carrying out one integration over this
over the second term only these numbers
also get
uh become the boundary terms
and now you know that because this is a
minus it becomes a minus but there will
be another minus so this minus and a
minus becomes a plus
and for this integration term
what we will be left with is a
is this d dx of
e i d cubed w d x square
okay so just like we had done the d d x
of that first term
uh which is present here we have the d
dx
of this first term which is present here
and of course we have this data w
present here
so now we are set
you see in both the integration terms
that we have present
we have achieved our goal of
obtaining a term which involves this
delta w
without any derivatives here also there
is no derivative here also there is no
derivative
so we can clump these two integration
terms together and what we are left with
here is just the boundary terms
okay so let me write this again
in the in the next page
so i have let me take a look back
i have this term eig square w dx square
then i have this d delta w dx
proper limits minus
e i e cube w
d x cube
take a look back just left with this
delta w
and then i have
0 to l
so i'm going to club this up this term
and this
this term here so again i'm going to
take this e i out of this
out of this differentiation so i'll be
left with
ei
d4w dx is 4
sorry x4
minus q
multiplied this whole thing multiplied
by delta w
dx and you can take a look that this is
indeed so
okay so this e i d 4 w dx
4 and this minus q and this entire thing
gets multiplied by this delta w
so this thing is equal to 0. now
using our knowledge from the calculus of
variations chapter
we can conclude that our
governing equation
is going to be the coefficient of this
delta w
term okay so this is exactly
the kind of thing which we did while
obtaining the euler lagrange equation
so this uh this governing equation that
we are going to write here
this is the euler lagrange equation for
this particular mechanical
system under concern so our governing
equation
will be the coefficient of this delta w
term here
which is nothing but eid for w dx is 4
minus q is equal to 0 and
for the boundary conditions all that you
have to do
is deal
with these boundary terms so what we say
is that
we consider this term first and then we
consider this term
second so what we're going to say is
that at
x equal to 0 and
x equal to l
you must be very careful in writing this
thing properly okay
so at x equal to 0 and at
x equal to l what we have is that either
we have this thing to be equal to 0
either e i
d square w d x square
is equal to zero or and this is very
very important to
write properly or
this dwdx is specified
what we mean by that is uh what we are
actually thinking is like this
that e i d squared w d x squared is
equal to zero
or this entire thing this d delta w d x
equal to zero
now d delta w dx equal to 0 is like
delta of d w d x equal to 0
now that basically means that if the
first variation of anything is
equal to 0 it must be so that that
thing of which we are taking the first
variation
that is a given to us okay so
uh what we are writing here is that for
d w
d x we we are not going to say that d w
d x is equal to zero
rather it is extremely important to
write that dw dx
is something which is specified to us
it is specified it need not be zero okay
because all that we need to ensure
is that the first variation the delta of
dw dx
which is of course equal to d delta w dx
which is what is which is present here
the the delta the first variation of
this dw dx is equal to 0
and that first variation of dw dx will
be equal to 0
if dw dx is actually specified to us
because if it is specified then there is
no question of its variability
which means that the first variation of
that has to be equal to
0 which is all that we need here okay
so that is quite a mouthful to say but
it is extremely extremely important to
write this down properly
in a similar fashion again we go go to
this term
and write this again at x equal to 0
and x equal to l
we have either
this first part e i d cube w d x cubed
that is equal to 0
or w is specified to us
again in in the same fashion that we had
we had discussed
the uh the zero here here also we should
not be
uh suddenly writing that w is equal to
zero
rather we should be very careful in
saying that it is
w which is just specified to us because
if it is specified to us
then the first variation of that is of
course going to be equal to zero
okay so this is our governing equation
and these two statements they together
make up our boundary conditions
and please note that this these these
boundary conditions have come up to us
in the form of this either or statements
because back when we were we were
discussing
our statement of the problem of this
general schematic of our problem
we had not actually specialized to any
particular boundary condition
we had left it as it is okay so this
could be simply supported this could be
clamped anything
okay it could be free so so just take a
look
at what we have managed to obtain here
so suppose indeed
that at x equal to 0 we have
the end as clamped if it is clamped
then the deflection of that is prevented
if the deflection of that is presented
you note
that what is basically going on is that
the w is specified there and this is the
part where it will be
uh which is what is going to be applied
so if the end is clamped at x equal to
zero what we are going to say is that
at x equal to zero this w is specified
and if this w is specified then you
cannot
say that at x equal to zero this is true
okay so either one of these has to uh be
applied
similarly if the end x equal to l
uh is also clamped then again you have
to say that w
specified at x equal to l which means
that at x equal to l you can no longer
say anything about this
so that is the significance of this
either or statement
at a particular end or at a particular
boundary once you
zero in on a particular or once you hone
in on a particular
uh option of this
okay the other option automatically gets
deleted from your consideration
similarly for the clamped and we know
that the slope is basically uh specified
to us which means that this dwdx is
specified to us
so again for that and that clamped
clamped end what we'll have is that at x
equal to zero and at x equal to l the d
w dx is specified to us
okay which automatically means that at
both x equal to 0 and x equal to l
this this other condition that will
automatically
that automatically need not be
considered
all right again alternatively suppose we
have
at x equal to zero a simply supported
end
which means that at that end uh there is
no
uh no restriction regarding the slope
means that t w dx is not specified to us
if it is not specified to us then it is
the other one which is going to get
applied so for a simply supported end we
have this e i d square w d x
square equal to 0 and you understand
what that means
okay so ei d square w dx
square it basically is so you see this
is what
e i 1 by r so this is like the moment
okay so e i 1 by r this is the moment so
moment is equal to 0 and that is exactly
true for a simply supported
end again let's say
at x equal to l you have a
free end so if it is a free end then
certainly our w is not specified
so if it is not specified then this
simply does not get uh this simply does
not get applied
rather this gets applied and what is
this this
from our undergraduate knowledge is
nothing but the shear force at that
end at x equal to l so overall you see
as a combination of this x equal to zero
and x equal to l
uh both here and here uh what we must
end up for every being problem
uh is a set of four boundary conditions
okay so at x equal to zero you have two
uh two conditions from these two
statements and at x equal to l
you have two conditions from these two
statements so both of them will
get applied at both the ends in total
you have four conditions
and that must be so that we we do end up
with four boundary conditions
because our governing equation is a
fourth order
ordinary differential equation involving
the w so
if you do manage to integrate this thing
to obtain the solution
you will end up with four constants of
integration in order to obtain the
values of those four constants of
integration you do need four boundary
conditions
okay so overall this is a nice
consistent closed
uh system of solution of of equations to
solve
uh and for particular problems you can
you can go ahead and find
your solutions so on that note i will
end this
lecture thank you very much